c'est aujourd'hui le jour super
intéressant et j'attendais depuis allez
le payer un petit moment c'est le retour
de samsung en france au niveau des
ordinateurs avec l'arrivée d'une gamme
book 2 et pour en parler en est avec
williams ali williams et aurélien
comment ça va bien je vais très bien je
t'aime mon temps de te retrouver
notamment aussi sur voir à barcelone ça
faisait longtemps c'est un beau temps
est court il n'y avait jamais embêté
mais vous imaginez même pas comment j ai
toujours il ya les arrive pour les ordis
zai quand il m'a dit on verra on verra
et là ils sont là voilà ça c'est la
nouveauté effectivement du mwc alors je
me situe quand même le mwcc le gros
salon de la téléphonie internationale
mais samsung étant leader de la
téléphonie et faisant des liens très
forts au niveau de l'écosystème et bien
il ya un lien c'est vraiment intéressant
c'est qu'on vient de voir ici de cette
notion d'écosystème avec les galaxy
boucle
[Musique]
william parce que tu peux m'expliquer un
peu ce que ça raconte alors un ordi on
sert à ça sert on sait comment ça marche
on a dû windows ok mais chez vous il ya
un truc un peu à part c'est vraiment
cette idée que tout fonctionne ensemble
de façon simple et transparente exane a
expliqué que je veux t'en remercie est
ravi de te voir aujourd'hui on commence
les next à l'heure alors ils les
galaxies beaucoup l'idée c'est que alors
on va être évidemment sur des pc qui ont
des caractéristiques vraiment très haut
de gamme comme un écran super amoled
comme les derniers processeurs intel
cetera et cetera mais la petite chose
qui va y avoir en plus et notamment pour
nos possesseurs de smartphones galaxy 2
tablettes galaxy c'est les fonctions
d'écosystèmes et d'expériences connecter
entre les appareils c'est pour ça que
revient en france avec ses ordinateurs
parce qu'on estime que ça y est on a la
maturité dans les produits pour pouvoir
le faire et pouvoir proposer quelque
chose qui se démarque vraiment de la
concurrence sur cette partie là et vous
étiez parti en quelle année ça fait quoi
tu faisais depuis 2015 oui si en france
on est partis au milieu de la décennie
dernière donc 2015 après sept ans ça y
est on revient et on lance du coup ces
quatre produits et galaxy book 2 avec
notamment le galaxy book de pros alors
je serai l'on parle des produits
permettent de couper vous êtes parti
vous êtes revenu pourquoi parce qu'il
fallait vraiment compléter l'écosystème
parce qu'on sent qu'il ya un changement
au niveau du pc les gens reviennent plus
vers du pc peut-être lié à la crise
coville ou pas du tout ou alors il ya
deux choses qui expliquent notre tour la
première chose c'est qu'on a quand même
changé d'état d'esprit depuis quelques
années chez samsung on est beaucoup plus
logique d'écosystème que deux lancements
de produits en silo sépare famille un
produit comme on le faisait auparavant
et on estimait que les ordinateurs est
un peu la dernière brique qui nous
manquait en france pour cette histoire
il ya quand même des gens qui nous
réclamait ans
de notre communauté des tablettes vous
avez des smartphones vous avez des
matchs il montre l ordinateur donc
essaion est de retour et et on pense
qu'on a les bons produits pour le faire
la deuxième chose est effectivement va
pas te mentir en disant que depuis deux
trois ans on a quand même cet usage qui
revient de l'ordinateur parce que on
travaille plus à la maison parce que
voilà c'est ce qui s'est produit l'autre
est d usage comme la visioconférence
revient dans notre quotidien et du coup
on est aussi un peu moins dans ce
paradigme où avant on avait les pc pour
travailler les smartphones pour rester
connecter les tablettes pour gagner
d'être fixe schématiser là on a vraiment
des produits qui sont capables de tout
faire en même temps qu'elle soit le
smartphone la tablette et le pc est
effectivement c'est un vrai retour pour
ce banquier alors tu me dis une nouvelle
famille galaxy book deux peuvent
expliquer la gamme pour qu'on comprenne
vraiment comment elle s'articule en fait
c'est très simple vous avez quatre
châssis dans cette gamme galaxy book
d'eux qu'ils se divisent de la façon
suivante la famille galaxy boucle d'eau
est divisée entre les modèles pro et les
modèles classiques et dans chacune de
ses familles vous avez une version 360
donc un écran donc qui pivote à 360 et
un format un peu plus classiques comme
celui là ok qui piquent 25 ans 160
exactement 10 n'atteindra plus tard
c'est ça donc si je vais par exemple sur
le terrain de la gamme pro 2 modèles
donc le book de croquis et celui ci
voilà alors que toutes les dernières
innovations plus l'écosystème et dans un
format classique entre guillemets et
lebouc de pro 360 qui lui est un écran
tactile un espen qui est inclus et du
quad et un écran qui se retourne
complètement ok ça nous fait quatre
modèles en tout alors tu me parles de
notions de l'écosystème parce que pour
vous c'est un truc important alors avant
qu'on a eus clown à la notion
d'écosystème tu me disais qu'on était
sur deux intel core de deuxième
génération on les sort du tagueur l'oeil
oui tout à fait ok donc est ce qui nous
permet d'avoir des ordinateurs
extrêmement léger c'est vraiment
bluffant gens cliquent que j'ai devant
moi ça c'est un modèle 15 pouces
exactement c'est léger en finesse 11 mm
d'épaisseur mais sur le 13 pouces qui a
essayé on est sous les 900 grammes en
termes de poids c'est incroyable donc
ouais c'est des choses tout cas chez
samsung qu'on n'a jamais vues jusqu'à
présent qu'on est fier de ramener en
france alors ces ordinateurs qui vont
aussi avoir quelques sas certaines
limites parce que si vous avez des
usages de gaming c'est pas les machines
qui seront qui sont faites pour vous par
contre davantage pour de la productivité
pour venir regarder et bien des films
des séries relevé des emails pouvoir
travailler d'un peu partout on pense
notamment au format 13 pouces qui va
être plus petit donc facile à
transporter et un 15 pouces un peu plus
grand ou alors ce qu'on a besoin d'un
peu plus de confort visuel ça peut être
intéressant alors parle de l'écosystème
parce que c'est vraiment un truc qui est
fort chez vous pour l'instant on l'a peu
abordée dans la surface mais
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pour ceux qui vous regardent vous avez
cette interface qui est là et quand vous
lancez l'ordinateur vous voyez toutes
les fonctions qui existe entre deux
produits galaxy et qui sont utilisables
dont vous donne quelques exemples pour
travailler samsung note vous avez la
possibilité de synchroniser tous vos
notre un ordinateur samsung une tablette
samsung galaxy s le galaxy s ça veut
dire que je commence à bosser sur mon
samsung galaxy s 22 ultra wii ou sur ma
table et suite ultra ça monte dans le
cloud grâce à mon compte samsung lessard
descendent directement dans mon
ordinateur exactement ça se fait en
temps réel un autre exemple pour la
productivité on avait montré dans une
autre vidéo mais la fonction de deuxième
écran puis six autres tablettes et pc
donc ça c'est génial ce que chez samsung
on propose des tablettes on propose des
pc on a des tablettes sous android des
pc sous windows mais pour autant il est
possible de les connecter entre eux pour
diffuser le deuxième écran de son pc sur
sa tablette android ont bien failli y
perdre qu'à y aurait cette fois partie
boulot entre autres il ya plein d'autres
fonctions mais dans quelques-unes ans a
duré une demi-heure à la vidéo
exactement on n'a peut-être pas envie
que de travailler avec son ordinateur on
a peut-être envie de consulter des
photos de retoucher un peu ce genre de
choses est là pour ça on a d'autres
fonctions qui existe dans la galerie par
exemple la gazette vous allez retrouver
ça va être l'application samsung galerie
donc je retrouve exactement la même
application que j'ai sur mon smartphone
et sur mon ordinateur pour la partie
galerie et imaginons que j'ai envie de
retoucher une photo comme celle ci voyez
elle est là bon évidemment je pourrais
dimensionné mes fenêtres etc mais si je
veux la retouche et hop voyez engranger
les mêmes les mêmes icônes que j'ai
habituellement sur mon smartphone est
pas forcément uniquement les icônes de
la visionneuse de base vraiment des
synergies dans l'interface qui existe et
en plus ce qui est génial c'est que si
je veux partager mais mes photos j'ai
pas forcément
besoin de me les envoyer par mail via
des applications tierces et ses jets
quick cher que vous connaissez peut-être
déjà parce que tu en avais parlé sur la
chaîne mais qui permet en fait de
rentrer à paris galaxie de se partager
des fichiers directement en wi fi direct
donc ça permet de conserver la qualité
jongler facilement entre les appareils
ces personnes et pour finir sur un parti
que ce système on a aussi les galaxies
bugs qui en font partie et aujourd'hui
quand vous allez par exemple ouvrir aux
galaxies buzz vous allez avoir une pop
up qui s'affiche automatiquement sur
l'écran alors un petit temps de quelques
secondes elle va s'afficher mais surtout
quand vous allez regarder un film soit
galaxie book est quelqu'un vous appelle
sur les smartphones fasse
automatiquement l'appel passer
automatiquement de la lotte et l'a75 ont
sauvé la voir avec la tablette et avec
le smartphone sera exactement d'accord
il aura en fait vous vous êtes dit on va
répliquer l'usagé qu'on va voir par
exemple avec une tablette pour l'adapter
à un ordinateur et au monde du pc
exactement quel compris et ce alors
juste pour finir sa partie écosystèmes
et ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
est dans un écosystème ouvert chez
samsung et du coup on a beaucoup de
synergies avec microsoft notamment et il
ya des choses que je n'ai pas montré
mais une application comme link to
windows permet de dupliquer les crampons
smartphone sur son pc les notes que
j'enregistre samsung note je peux les
exporter dans what not la galerie est
synchronisé quan drive donc on a
vraiment des synergies avec microsoft
également sur ce sujet là et on n'est
pas forcément enfermer chez samsung ok
est-ce que je peux utiliser par exemple
connecter mon smartphone sur mon pc est
passé mes coups de fil directement
depuis montpellier ça c'est passage à
l'attaqué mais à sa nage depuis mon pc
également c'est possible mais toutes ces
choses là qui sont vachement
intéressante ok donc là tu me parle
effectivement de galaxies goût de croo
on a un modèle 360 qui permet de pivoter
totalement l'écran on l'a où on l'a
berne ou pas exactement ici ok on va on
va l'installer vous avez le s pen qui va
avec celui là il va qu'avec le modèle
360 lespade exactement à côté donc
l'idée voilà je pouvais le passer en 360
et donc je peux aller
la démonstration n'est pas très
intéressante mais dans une application
de notes une affection de dessin ou pour
les plus créatifs on peut vraiment s'en
servir comme un super outil j'en écran
de 15 pouces en plus sur celui ci en
plus on a du super bowl est donc c'est
génial c'est hyper canon celui-là il
s'adresse plutôt à qui ce modèle là
s'adresse plutôt aux créatifs tout ce
qui va aller aller un peu plus loin
après ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est
que même sans l'aspect 360 mhz écran est
tactile même dans un usage qu'un clavier
on sait qu'on a des gens qui préfèrent
l'usagé tactile ou manier les deux donc
vous pouvez vraiment lié les deux clans
classe ça veut dire que je t'ai liskamm
un ordinateur un petit peu standard oui
si je veux travailler avec mon esprit je
peux le faire que le maître comme tu
disais tout à l'heure sur un espèce de
mode un peu cheval est exactement que
par et puis je peux totalement revenir
le replier pour mettre sur mes genoux
pour travailler et là où quelqu'un à mon
clavier désactiver exactement malaise
serait tout à prix il faut savoir on
peut tout faire avec c'est vachement
pratique et surtout j'insiste de sion
d'un écran super amoled qui est
magnifique et ça aussi c'est c'est l'une
de nos plus values quand on revient sur
un marché comme ça c'est que revient
avec notre maîtrise des écrans qu'on a
surtout le s pen c'est celui que je vais
retrouver avec matin des suites ultra
alors je sais que l'espagne sont
compatibles entre les modes de modèles
donc d'accord utiliser le smn une
tablette ultra d'accord doit tout à fait
honnête celui ci est un espèce de table
et surtout ultra hockey puisque je
n'avais pas le s pen qui correspond à
cet ordinateur parce qu'ils n'ont pas du
tout oui il sera dans la boîte il sera
dans la boîte d'accord ici explique jill
directement cette machine à exactement
ok tu n'es pas sans savoir que tout est
lié à l'écran finalement donc souvent
nos espagne sont compatibles à claude
appareils et c'est l'écran qui vient
gérer tout à fait d'accord ok dans
l'équation du 84 me 96 points de
pression là-dessus j'imagine oui c'est
ça au niveau de la latence des
informations par rapport à la tendance
par rapport à ce qu'on a sur une
clavicule train tu vois je n'ai pas le
chiffre exact je le retrouve mais tu
veux être sur ce qu'on sait forcément
faire de très bien chez samsung devrait
donc si jamais tu n'es pas sur les 2,8
millisecondes me semble-t-il hattab est
ultra tout sera peut-être sur les 7
millisecondes d'une autre vin ya deux
ans d'accord qui devront qu'on sera
vraiment sur des filiales intox ou
excellent d'accord j'ai compris donc là
tu me disais on est sur une pelle core 2
12e jeunes du tiger laïque on l'est
surtout pour la survie ils s'inquiètent
oui alors tu vois plusieurs confieront
les châssis par exemple sur un bouc de
pro qui est là on va voir soit du 5 soit
de 8,7 également différents niveaux
drame et de stockage qui sont
disponibles par contre sur le book de
croo 360 on a fait le choix de
uniquement proposer la version la plus
véloce donc en 1749 ça mûrisse suivre
tous les usagers hyper véloce du
quotidien sur steam de haut niveau de la
ram on est sur un surcroît il fit passer
pareille aura soin des configurations
henry 5 avec une gamme dédiée 77 et par
exemple sur un bouc deux pros 360 on a
choisi de proposer d'un core i7 16 giga
de ram et 512 giga stockage d'accord
c'est la profit de la plus poussée sur
un bouc de pro plus classique tu aura le
choix entre du vck drame en 256 go de
stockage ou du 16e gadrat bon ça semble
choquer et une part est alors d'un bloc
de charge 60 100 watts et sort qui va
être compatible avec tous mes produits
c'est-à-dire mon smartphone avec ma
table à quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui on
les smartphones ya plus de blocs de
charge donc dans l'idée où je m'achète
un galaxy boudeuse de la gamme
exactement un bon bloc de chair 65 watts
qui permettra de charger mon smartphone
la tablette très rapidement exactement
en fait on a un bloc de charge qui est
hyper intéressant parce que il est hors
et il est compact il se rapproche un peu
de ce qu'on voit sur les smartphones et
leurs 65 watts et celle du sbc et du
coup avec celui ci on pouvait les
charges chargé sa tablette son
smartphone ces bugs si on souhaite la
même d'autres appareils
du milieu de la photo des consoles de
jeux donc c'est vraiment universel et
c'est très pratique au quotidien a mené
partout écoute c'est vachement
intéressant moi j'ai hâte de découvrir
davantage qu'est ce que tu vas autres
choses à venir a ajouté qu'on n'aurait
pas ni ne fume pas je dois parler
l'écosystème je crois
je pense qu'on a fait le tour l'idée
c'est qu'on est vraiment de retour en
france avec ces produits là il ya une
vraie approche éco système je pense que
j'ai martelé le mot mais qui est très
importante pour nous dans ce tour là
d'accord sans faire de concessions sur
toutes les innovations technologiques
capables d'apporter ces produits on a
une offre de précommande entre mars et
le disponibles et le premier date de
sortie c'est con alors du coup alors au
jour on se parle donc nous sommes le 28
février à barcelone en 2022 les produits
sortent le 1er avril 2022 en france dans
les magasins dans les magasins livraison
ou en livres chez un client lors de
nombreux comment diable est en fait à
partir du 18 mars vous pourrez le
commander en ligne donc soit chez
samsung choix de partir d'ailleurs
distributeurs et pour cette commande
vous aurez un moniteur donc un écran qui
est qui est offerte c'est une référence
de moniteurs qui est offerte et
attention on pouvait retrouver la
référence sur tous les sites non mais
c'est du 27 c'est très bien ok et les
tarifs on les a à peu près ou pas ah oui
en fait le produit qu'on n'a pas sous
les yeux mais sur l'e book de la gamme
qui n'est pas pro quand son nom on va
commencer à 799 euros sans qu'elle
confie sur de 8 5 et 8 gigas et 256 et
sur les boucles de cros on va être sur
un tarif plus élevé qui va dépasser la
barre des 1000 euros puisqu'on sera à
partir de 1299 d'accord ça marche et si
on regarde sur les modèles 360 et là on
sera plutôt aux alentours de 1500 euros
sur ce modèle là on a décidé de
commercialiser la version la plus
aboutie en 17 16 et 512 avec l'espagne
exactement pas fait bon ben écoute merci
beaucoup il ya avec plaisir que j'espère
que on a répondu à toutes les questions
mais moi je trouve ça vraiment
intéressant ce que je dis c'est que je
trouve vraiment attachant déjà tout ça
tout son écosystème année leurs efforts
allaient présenter sa ronde en vol
stratégie c'est très clair je trouve ça
aussi très bien mettre un des questions
j'ai mis en pause et moi c'est au cachet
sur un tiger et canon ça fait d'avoir un
truc en mobilité qui est vraiment bien
maintenant je me pose sur la question
moi 2000 usage unique sont très
particuliers notamment sur de la vidéo
je me dis ok est-ce que je peux
installer un premier arrêt faire des
choses dessus je suis pas convaincu de
pouvoir aller bien loin sur de l'édition
de kako si photoshop avec beaucoup de
calme qu'elles sont un peu les limites
mais ça c'est la question du tagueur
laïque vous vous avez fait un choix
d'avoir un produit qui est vraiment axé
productivité légèreté flexibilité
divertissement et ça c'est super
intéressant et puis on suivra bien
évidemment l'évolution de la gamme parce
que je pense que c'est que le début de
l'histoire en france lui qu'on verra les
gammes évoluer dans le temps donc très
bien voilà la découvrir et à tester à
tester chose que voilà soit partie
processeur
on a les derniers processeurs intel donc
donc c'est vraiment le trio de gamme
mais en fonction des usages de chacun
effectivement fois les poussées pour
voir ce que chacun peut y trouver
exactement génial merci beaucoup william
bell plaisir et merci à vous si vous
avez des question les idées des
suggestions sens un produit vous allez
martyr ben commentaires je pense qu'on
l'ait testera qu on les regardera parce
que c'est vachement intéressant quand le
retour de samsung en france au niveau du
monde du pc alors oui il ya nous dit
très justement il ya toute cette notion
d'écosystème qui est très forte chez
samsung mais même au delà de
l'écosystème qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
avec ces machines ya qui elles
s'adressent surtout ça qui est
intéressant donc on en reparlera donc si
vous avez des questions pour les marquer
juste en bas en commentaires dont se
trouve très rapidement pour continuer
bien évidemment à part les tec samsung
et tous les autres nous en avons assez
bientôt chaos
[Musique]